>> Today we have with us Josh Bazell.
Josh has a B.A. in English literature and
writing from Brown University and an M.D.
from Columbia.
Currently, he's a resident at the University
of California in San Francisco, just down
the way.
And he wrote, "Beat the Reaper," while completing
his internship at a hospital -- not at all
like the one that is described in the book.
Beat the Reaper has been described as "A hypochondriac's
nightmare and a reader's dream."
And it's his first book.
I believe he's working on a second.
So please welcome today, Josh Bazell.
>> [Clapping]
>> [pause]
Josh Bazell: Okay. Wait.
So this is actually -- I need to stand at
the podium too?
>> Yeah, so the.
Josh Bazell: Okay. Hi, I'm Josh Bazell. Thanks
for having me.
That's my dog Lotty, by the way, who appears
in various guises in the book several times.
I'm
sorry that this is a lunch-hour thing, because
I was going to talk about actually an incident
that began -- for me, about two months ago
-- when I got barfed on by a kid with swine
flu. [laughter]
>> [Inaudible]
Josh Bazell: Okay. I will do that.
I was on an airplane and they asked for a
doctor and I was asleep.
And so, I said, "Oh, I'm a doctor."
I mean, I woke up from it.
And the two people who announced themselves
on the plane were me and -- I'm on the sort
of indeterminant leave from my psychiatry
residency at UCSF, and the other guy was a
cardiologist who was sheik and had a turban.
So they were like, "We'll take the guy without
the turban."
And I ended up taking care of this kid, which
was fairly straightforward -- had mostly to
do with the people on the plane wanting to
stone him to death for having swine flu.
He was about nine and had been put on this
plane by himself by his mother who also had
swine flu.
I mean, it was an ugly story, but it certainly
wasn't the kid's fault.
He was so ill that the flight attendants just
noticed him in his seat as being sick.
So, you know, I spent sometime with him -- gave
him some fluids and so forth.
And the next day, I started to feel a little
under the weather, because I'm as hypochondriacal
as the next person.
And I called in a prescription for myself
-- which was something we can do for non-controlled
substances -- for tamiflu.
And when I went to pick it up, I was told
by the pharmacy that my insurance company
said I had no insurance and hadn't for six
months.
I'm on Cobra at the moment, and what's interesting
is, I've made four Cobra payments and all
four of them have resulted in the insurance
company saying they never got payment and
cutting me from the rolls, but also cashing
the checks.
And it wasn't this time a particularly big
deal, because I'd been through it three times
before.
I know what to do in terms of getting the
check copies and who to call and stuff.
It took about ten hours of work over the course
of a week.
And then, they said it was a mistake, which
is what has happened the previous times.
But what's kind of distressing -- because
it's not a big deal.
It wasn't in this case.
I mean, I didn't certainly die of swine flu.
What's kind of distressing is the clear implication
that if I were say, in a car accident, and
someone were to call my insurance company
-- which incidentally they do from the ambulance
-- and it absolutely changes the course of
your health care from the moment they find
you in terms of what hospital they sent you
to and so forth.
If they had done that, the insurance company
would have said I was not insured and it would
have just been a very different course of
care.
And it occurred to me to wonder -- not so
much how insurance companies could operate
like that, because they're companies and they're
going to be as rapacious as they're allowed
to be.
I'm not that interested in the individuals
who work for these companies, because I think
it's, you know -- people are scared right
now and they're very shortsighted.
There's this sort of epidemic in the country
of this thing called 'family values' -- which
means that, if you care for your family, you
don't have to care for anybody else.
But I was slightly curious about why the rules
are so lax in terms of insurance companies.
And the same thing is true with pharmaceutical
companies.
I don't know if you guys know this, but basically,
the issue with pharmaceutical companies is
advertising.
They all spend more on advertising than they
do on research.
They advertise to doctors.
They advertise, "Oh, hello."
Sorry, I didn't mean to embarrass you. [chuckle]
So they advertise to consumers directly, which
is legal in this country.
It's also legal in New Zealand.
It's not legal in any other industrialized
country, but it will be soon, because the
Internet has made it basically impossible
to keep advertisements out of any specific
country.
And you know, these rules that they have -- the
pharmaceutical industry in particular -- the
rule that really favors them is one that the
FDA has, which is that, If you invent a new
medication, all you have to do to get it approved
to show that it has some advantage over placebo.
You don't have to test it against medications
that are already on the market.
The result of this is, if you invent a medication
that works one-sixth as well as something
that's already out there and has ten times
as many side effects, you can nonetheless
spend a billion dollars advertising it and
make reliably 2.1 billion dollars.
And obviously, they're going to do this, because
they're allowed to do this.
And they're allowed to do this because they
pay our Congress people.
There's been an interesting jump this year.
In 2008, the health care industry paid members
of Congress about $95 million.
This year so far, it's about $390 million.
And again, they get what they want out of
that.
They also do other interesting things.
Sanofi Pasteur is particularly interesting
company in that they got $10 million from
the bailout, which they seemed to have spent
entirely on hiring DLA Piper, which -- at
the time -- was starring former Senate majority
leader Dick Army, the Republican.
And what they did for Sanofi was send fake
protesters to town hall meetings this summer,
which was incredibly effective.
I just started wondering after my own insurance
run-in, why any of this is legal.
And I just found the answer to be somewhat
interesting.
I thought, you know, perhaps there ought to
be laws against buying off your Congress people.
And it turns out that there, in fact, are
laws.
There are many laws.
One in particular is U.S. Code 18201, which
says that you cannot give any member of Congress
-- past, present, or future -- any consideration
in return for a decision that they make in
the course of their duties.
And the Senate Ethics Committee Handbook sums
this up as saying, "Don't take anything of
value from anyone for doing anything."
So it would seem, sort of on the face of it,
that for these guys -- when you start out
in the Senate you make about $185,000 a year,
which seems like a fair amount to me given
that the job is apparently so easy you can
run for President full-time while doing it.
But just for comparison, it's about four times
as much as you can make as a firefighter in
the U.S.
after 20 years on the job anywhere in the
country.
But this amount for key members of Congress
is absolutely dwarfed by the money coming
in from these companies.
And why is that legal?
Well, there are various loopholes.
For instance, the major one is this sort of
fiction that, If you donate to a candidate's
campaign, you are not giving them something
of any value.
This is the way it's sort of treated.
Money goes into campaigns.
Incidentally though, the limit that a campaign
can accept is $2,500 from a person and zero
from a corporation.
You have to launder the money through political
action committees, which is done all the time.
And the basis of this acceptance of this practice
is twofold.
One is the argument that "Corporations have
to be able to donate to campaigns somehow
to level the playing field, otherwise new
candidates will have no chance of raising
money." which I think is a legitimate concern,
although it's hard to see how it actually
works since the incumbents are so heavily
favored in most Senate races right now.
And they get the most of the money, which
sort of causes the system to persist.
But the more interesting concept is that the
corporations have First Amendment rights and
also Fourteenth Amendment protections.
Are you guys familiar with the Fourteenth
Amendment?
Basically, this was an amendment in 1868 that
was designed entirely to overturn the Dred
Scott decision and give black people rights
in the U.S. after the Civil War.
And it did that fairly well.
And then, in 1886 -- right in our neck of
the woods -- there was a law case called Santa
Rosa vs. Pacific Southern Railroad, in which
the railroad was saying they wanted a tax
break from land that they owned that was losing
value.
They wanted to amortize their losses as taxes.
And they did win the case.
And the decision doesn't mention the Fourteenth
Amendment at all, but there's something called
the 'head note', which was written by the
stenographer in the case -- who, interestingly,
was employed at the time by the Southern Pacific
Railroad.
And he said in passing that the justices felt
strongly that corporations, like individuals,
should have Fourteenth Amendment protections.
This is one of the most important Supreme
Court decisions of all time.
I mean, it's not even a decision. It's quasi.
Numerous justices have pointed it out as being
possibly the most operative law in the country.
There's a case going on right now called Citizens
United vs. Federal Election Committee, which
is more commonly known as the People vs. Hillary
Clinton case.
Do you guys know this?
During the recent election cycle, this group
called Citizens United made a movie about
Hillary Clinton that sort of hatchet piece
that the Federal Elections Commission said
that they could not show within 60 days of
the election, because you can't air issue
ads by third parties within 60 days of an
election.
And they are suing right now.
The case has reached the Supreme Court.
Actually, the arguments have already been
heard before the start of the session, which
was -- is it still October?
It is -- which was earlier this month.
It was actually -- on September ninth, there
was an emergency session.
Sonya Sotomayor was sworn in early just for
this session and they went and heard these
arguments.
But there's no -- and it's possible that the
Supreme Court will say, "Well, this is too
specific a case, and we're going to deal with
this case and not the larger case law."
But it's also likely -- given the make-up
of the Supreme Court -- that they're going
to uphold Fourteenth Amendment rights for
corporations.
Incidentally, the original case in 1886 -- if
the Supreme Court really did say that corporations
should have Fourteenth Amendment -- means
that corporations got equal rights and citizenship
protection well before women did, on the order
of about 40 years.
So this is the issue; this is what we're facing.
What's interesting, to me, about corporations
is that they're kind of like vampires.
I mean, not in the parasitic way, although
certainly pharmaceutical companies and insurance
companies are that.
But just in the sense that, When you give
a person protection and you give them citizenship,
they eventually tend to die, and that sort
of evens things out -- at least a little bit,
depending on what the inheritance laws are.
With corporations, that's just not the case.
Corporations can theoretically go on forever.
And they don't have to -- you know, there
are not issues with movement of their resources.
So that's really kind of what we're up against.
I should say my book, Beat the Reaper, is
a sort of nuar comedy about hospital life
in the Mafia, which has nothing to do with
any of this.
But one thing that I was kind of wondering,
because when you work as a physician, there's
this sort of scorpions-in-a-bottle scenario
that you often face, where the patients are
furious at you, doctors are often really angry
too.
And I think it's mostly because they're the
two parties that they see.
And things are not going well with health
care right now.
Actually, I say in the book at one point -- there's
a patient in a very fancy ward at this hospital
and I make the point -- which incidentally
is accurate -- that these fancy wards often
have the worst health care in the hospital.
They tend to be sort of retirement legs for
people who are done with their work elsewhere
in the hospital.
And the comment that I make is that, "If you
don't believe that health care can be worse
-- even if you pay much more money for it
-- you should forget these polls about how
the U.S. is the 37th ranked health care system
and just take a look at Michael Jackson."
I was in Spain two weeks ago and the translation
of the book -- they use a different verb for
"take a look at."
It's 'fijarse', which is sort of like 'fixate
on'.
And the implication seemed to be there that
I had somehow predicted that Jackson was going
to die -- which is not at all the case, but
was very exciting for me at the time.
They were asking me, you know, who else was
going to go, and that kind of thing.
Why am I on this topic?
I don't know. Anyway. It's interesting.
I mean, to me, Google's sort of fascinating.
Google is at the very beginning of its lifespan,
which we don't get to see all that often.
It's also a company -- I mean, we have an
idea of what Microsoft was like at its absolute
inception, but it also seems to have been
run really by two guys for years.
Whereas Google, very quickly, has enjoyed
many more employees.
And it's just -- it's curious to watch from
the outside, particularly if you're from San
Francisco.
So I'm curious -- maybe you don't want to
answer this on tape, but -- is there a sense
of sort of 'democratic governance' in this
company?
Like, do you guys feel like you could shift
company policy?
Okay. I'll take that as a neither/nor.
I mean, I can tell you as a civilian and a
nonGoogle member.
The question that's on my mind is -- because
Google has this motto of, what is it?
Don't do evil. Don't be evil. Don't see, hear,
or speak? [laughter]
Right. "Do no evil."
And it seems to me they've done pretty well
at that at the time.
I mean, obviously there have been these sort
of tough squabbles with the China situation
and so forth.
But the question is, Is Google going to get
tired of being Google at some point and sell
the information base?
-- which would be really only one evil act,
but it would be pretty evil.
It would go backwards and forwards in time
and would negate a lot of what we love about
Google so much.
So, as a side note, I would like to simply
say, "Please don't do that." [laughter]
And that's pretty much all I have to say.
[laughter]
If anybody has any questions, I'm happy to
answer.
Q Did you talk about writing in the book at
all while you were working in your position
there?
Josh Bazell: Yeah, I wrote this book during
my last year of med school and my first year
of residency, which is also called 'internship.'
And it seems -- I mean, people always say,
"Oh, how did you do that? That's so insane."
It's not that insane.
The last year of medical school is relatively
cushy.
And even -- the thing that's great about internship
is, it is at times extremely time consuming,
but it tends also to be very ordered.
Like, you know in advance on a month-to-month
basis what your free time is going to look
like.
And if you're willing to have sort of "no
life outside of writing and medicine" -- which
I was willing to do at the time.
I mean, it really wasn't -- it was not so
much of a hassle.
I've been writing my whole life.
I started wanting to be a novelist when I
was nine, after reading The Godfather and
Jaws -- both of which sort of manifest heavily
in this book.
And I've worked as a professional writer for
sixteen years.
Most of that was in movies.
This is my first published book.
So it was pretty reflexive.
Q What led you to want to eventually go from
that goal of wanting to be a full-time writer
to medicine?
Josh Bazell: I always wanted to go to med
school for several reasons.
One, just that it was interesting.
Like, I wanted to know that stuff.
And I found like I wasn't really able to learn
it on my own.
I mean, it's almost like a drive for trivia
on the one hand.
The other issue was, I was in a Ph.D. program
in English literature at Duke.
And I was so depressed that I thought, "If
I'm going to be this depressed for this many
years, I might as well go into medicine where,
whatever I'm feeling, at least I'm helping
somebody else in the course of the day." [laughter]
And I have to say, medicine is fantastic for
that. I mean, it really is.
It really doesn't matter how you're feeling.
You really can actually -- I mean, you can
make a slight difference each day almost by
default.
And that was very helpful to me.
It's tough now that I'm on leave, actually.
I mean, what's weird is, like -- I'm on leave.
I'm not even doing that much writing.
I mean, thankfully, the book has been a big
hit worldwide.
It's out in 35 languages now.
And the result is that I often travel to countries
that are releasing it on these sort of staggered
schedules.
And it often seems like my full-time job now
is publicity, which is not something I ever
had an interest in.
I'm not particularly good at it.
And it's just interesting.
I mean, on the axis of how one lives one's
life from say a zero of "going into banking,
going to marry somebody else in banking, we're
going to get a nanny to take care of our child
who will eventually go into banking" [laughter]
And to say at the top like, "I'm going to
be a nun and help the poor in India."
I do feel like I backslid a little bit in
the last year.
Sir.
Q In terms of reforming the health care system,
how do you assess the strength and weakness
of fictional writing versus [inaudible]?
Josh Bazell: Right. Well, fictional writing
is a lot easier to do.
I wonder sometimes if it's sheer laziness
that drives me down the fictional route, although
I love fiction. I read fiction all the time.
I have written a series of essays about the
health care debate, so called.
It's not really a debate.
I mean, any doctor who actually cares about
his or her patients knows that 'single payer'
is the way to go.
And the 'public option' is the sort of second
best.
I mean, there is no debate other than corporations
successfully advertising and buying senators.
I have written about it.
I have much less success as a nonfiction writer.
I do occasional pieces in the New York Times,
which is fun, but they like me to be sort
of less serious.
I assume that's what you mean as sort of editorializing
rather than publishing studies.
Q I was thinking about some of those articles
in the New Yorker magazine.
I don't even call it [inaudible]
Josh Bazell: Atul Gawande is a surgeon at
Harvard who has written frequently.
And obviously Malcolm Gladwell does a lot
also.
Q Yeah, right. I was just curious about your
perspective on the impact.
I mean, impact in all different kinds of venues
of fiction versus nonfiction quarterly article.
Josh Bazell: I think also it's a little -- I
did a talk that ended up being somewhat of
a debate with a pharm rep recently, because
the pharm rep had gotten up and said, "We
haven't published this, but we had data that
-- not only is our product better, other
corporation's products are harming people."
It was about osteoporosis.
And that's fiction, right? I mean, they may
have such data.
They may have written that data down five
minutes ago on a napkin.
I mean, you know, a little bit -- it's like
the Calvin and Hobbes, "They lie; we lie."
kind of scenario, where there are certain
things you can get across in fiction that
you can not get across in an essay, I think.
Things like thought patterns.
I mean, you can interview people extensively
and try and capture that, but to really mock
up what somebody is thinking in a situation
in realtime?
I also -- I should say that, although there
are some inaccuracies in the book, there are
some intentional ones and also, I'm sure,
some unintentional ones.
There's a lot of facts in there.
I mean, I really do go out of my way to make
it as accurate as possible.
Sir.
Q [indecipherable]
Josh Bazell: Right. Just in case anybody doesn't
know what this is.
A single payer health care system is one in
which there is no insurance.
There is no gamble.
You're not putting up money because you think
something might happen to you.
And they're not taking your money hoping that,
either nothing happens to you or that they
can deny that something happened to you when
something happened to you -- or fail to take
responsibility for it.
Single payer means, The government pays for
health care.
They are not paying for insurance.
They are paying for actual health care.
If you go into the hospital, you got a broken
leg, they pay the doctor.
What we're looking at is some sort of very-watered-down
insurance system.
I mean, almost by definition -- you know -- these
corporations, that make so very much money,
are parasitic.
You know, the difference -- these are companies
-- the way an insurance company makes money
is by making this gamble with you.
And then, pushing the issue to try and win
on each case.
I mean, there's somebody in an office all
the time trying to figure out how to not to
pay for something that -- let's admit it -- in
some cases is fraudulent, but in most cases
isn't.
And just the idea that you can take out that
parasite from the loop, it would be such an
enormous savings -- not only in terms of money,
but also time.
I mean, dealing with an insurance company
is absolutely maddening.
And you know like this thing where they four
times in a row said they didn't get my check
that they had cashed.
At a certain point you've got to stop thinking
that's incompetence, because never once have
they said, "Oh, we got two checks from you."
You got to start thinking, "This is somebody
who's looking at the bottom line and has a
full-time job of figuring out essentially
how to rip people off."
And it just seems like getting rid of that
situation is not only theoretically better,
but it works better in other countries.
Sir.
Q And actually, if you try to repeat the question
if possible after each.
Josh Bazell: Oh, sure.
Q With regards to research on the book, obviously,
the doctor in med school here in the book
had died [inaudible]-- as far as the Mafia
side, did you term as Shylock at any point,
or how did you go about? [laughter]
Josh Bazell: No, I mean, I have a couple of
real world, underworld connections.
They're very minor.
I grew up in downtown Manhattan in a neighborhood
where there are a lot of guys who wanted you
to think they were mobsters.
I don't know if they were.
And the extent to which they were was never
really clear.
I mean, Vinnie "The Chin" was clearly an actual
mobster.
He lived about two blocks from me.
He was this guy who would wear a bathrobe
on the street so that, if he got indicted,
he could claim that he was crazy.
He wore this bathrobe for my entire childhood
and then got indicted and it didn't work.
[laughter]
His actual last name was Gigante.
I additionally used to work for the chief
medical examiner's office in New York City,
so I've seen some of the crime stuff from
that angle and I spent a lot of time with
police officers.
All that said, the real source of my information
is this sub-genre of "Mafia witness protection
tell all", which is the most disgusting sub-genre
of books I've ever come across.
There are these books -- and people go into
the witness protection program -- they write
a book, not least of which because you make
very little money generally in the witness
protection program, unless -- like Sammy the
Bull -- you're running the biggest ecstasy
ring in the country or something.
And these books are all about how sorry these
guys are that they committed these horrible
acts, but they're not really actually sorry
at all.
They just want to brag about how they used
to be able to get people beaten up and used
to get good tables at restaurants and stuff.
And the hypocrisy is just -- you want to take
a shower after you read these books.
But there's a lot of them.
And I continue to take the hit for the public
good of reading.
One thing that's really interesting is people
who have identified themselves to me, after
the book came out, as people with violent
backgrounds or criminal backgrounds who have
become health care professionals.
I have never -- I haven't seen a doctor who
used to be a hitman, but I've seen, you know,
I've seen bank robbers who are now physician's
assistants and stuff.
And it's really interesting.
And often it's very emotional to talk to them,
because they tend to be sort of the opposite
of these scum bags in the protection program.
These are people who really changed their
life, usually from a religious conversion.
Okay.
Q You're working on a second book now?
Josh Bazell: I am working on the second book
now.
Q Can you disclose that in a similar genre?
Josh Bazell: Oh yeah. It's actually a sequel.
It's a continuation.
It's not a sequel in the sense of, "This is
a series character, who's like exactly the
same in every book," but it does take place
afterwards.
I mean, it's -- he has taken the damage emotionally
and physically that he has taken in this book
and that carries forward.
So it's quite a different book, actually.
But I'm working on it.
Mr. Tsai, Dr. Tsai.
Q Have you given talks to primarily physician
audiences vs. primarily crime nuar type audiences?
Josh Bazell: The question is, Do I primarily
give talks to physicians or to readers?
It's about 50/50.
It does tend to be quite different -- I mean,
often if I go to a bookstore, I'll actually
read from the book or do some other lame thing
to sort of expose people to it.
Recently, the difference between the two audiences
has really become minimal, because everybody's
sort of freaked out about health care.
Or if they're not freaked out, I sort of make
it my personal business to freak them out.
[laughter]
Anyway, thank you guys so much for your time.
Thanks for the interest.